[Music]
we are now learning more about Tiger
Woods Memorial Day arrest there was
initial online speculation that the
golfing legend was intoxicated and
smelled of alcohol when police pulled
him over with woods released a statement
saying that alcohol was not a factor
quote what happened was an unexpected
reaction to prescribed medications and
according to the police report a
breathalyzer administered at the scene
failed to detect any alcohol but still
this latest scandal could do massive
damage to an already large brain Tigers
DUI puts at risk over 40 million dollars
in endorsement income Michael oh honey
Anna Forbes is tracking the fallout from
Tigers arrest his biggest single payday
comes from his business arrangement with
Nike which pays him over 20 million
dollars annually in addition to Nike
Woods also endorses TaylorMade Golf
Clubs and Rolex watches so far Tigers
current corporate sponsors have mostly
been silent a spokesperson for
Bridgestone golf told ET quote we are
aware of the situation and will continue
to monitor
[Music]
Woods was arrested in Jupiter Florida
about three miles from his reported
sixty million dollar estate and about
three miles from his restaurant the
woods a jeweler named a tiger's
endorsements have taken previous hits in
late 2009 he confessed to being
unfaithful and his marriage soon ended
Tiger lost over 40 million dollars in
endorsement income when many endorsers
fled among them Buick and AT&T Nike
stood by woods through that public
relations challenge this arrests
happened his tiger is recovering from
his fourth serious back surgery in three
years and Tigers blog post on May 24th
the surgery seems successful Woods
posted words cannot convey how good it
feels to be pain-free Tiger has a
mandatory court appearance scheduled for
July 5th
[Music]
you